what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight Theory video as I'm sure most of
you know by now one of the biggest
mysteries in A Song of Ice and Fire and
Game of Thrones revolves around the
night King we were introduced to the
leader of the White Walkers back in the
fourth season of the show yet we still
don't know very much about this
character one thing we have learned
about the night King is he was created
by the children of the forest as a
weapon to protect them and their sacred
weirwood trees from getting cut down by
the first men the very few things we do
know about the White Walkers are only in
legend we have been told that they came
for the first time during a generational
long winter known as the long night
during this time the White Walkers
started to invade Westeros and according
to old man the White Walkers were on the
verge of wiping out the entire continent
that was until a legendary figure known
as the last hero found the children of
the forest together they were able to
somehow stop the White Walkers from
advancing any further south not only
that but the White Walkers actually fled
back into the icy north and we don't
know exactly what happened the truth
about how they were able to get the
fighting to stop is still unknown
to this day I have always assumed that
the last hero had to have came to some
kind of an agreement what the White
Walkers he had to have offered them
something they could not refuse or else
why would they even accept his offering
because based on all accounts the White
Walkers were winning the battle up until
that point all we do know is that the
White Walkers were not seen again for
thousands of years roughly 8,000 years
had passed without a single white Walker
sighting they had disappeared for so
long then most of our current characters
weren't even sure if they were real in
the first place all the White Walkers
White Walkers have been gone for
thousands of years so he was like
and that man sees what he sees that was
until some more credible characters
started to have some encounters with
them beyond the wall till this day no
one really knows how or why the White
Walkers in the night King decided to
come back now this is what I want to
talk about today what does the night
King and the White Walkers want the
interesting thing is they may have
already gave us the answer when the
night King was introduced the night
Kings introduction may have actually
been the foreshadowing for the end of
the series the very first time we met
the night King was back in season four
this was when we saw the white Walker
take one a crashed her son's all the way
to the lands of always winter one thing
we do know the night king once his fresh
recruits for his army we know this
because Chrysler was leaving his newborn
son's out in the woods as a sacrifice to
the White Walkers this is actually a
tradition that dates all the way back to
the Age of Heroes
when old nan tells us the story about
the night's king who was the 13th Lord
Commander at the Nights Watch we learned
that the night's king in the Nights
Queen we're also sacrificing their own
babies to the White Walkers now this is
interesting for a few different reasons
this actually lets us know that the
White Walkers are willing to negotiate
as long as you give them something in
return this makes me think that the last
hero may have offered something very
similar during the first long night like
I said we were told that the night's
king and Nights Queen were making
sacrifices to the White Walkers and we
were shown that Crestor was making
sacrifices to the White Walkers so maybe
this is the only thing that they are
willing to accept this allowed Crestor
and his daughters to continue to live
beyond the wall without having to worry
about getting attacked by the White
Walkers
now we're not exactly sure how Craster
was able to negotiate that deal with the
night king but either way i lets us know
that the night king does one at least
one thing and that is a newborn son this
sort of makes sense when you actually
think about why the White Walkers were
created in the first place we were told
that the children of the forest created
the way walkers because they were afraid
their own race was about to go extinct
the children of the forest were getting
slaughtered by the first men and their
numbers were so low that they actually
became an endangered species for you you
made the White Walkers
we're being slaughtered our sacred trees
cut down we need to defend ourselves so
in order to save themselves they created
a weapon that they thought could wipe
out the entire human race the night king
most likely once would everyone else
once just like what the humans in the
children the night king is trying to
keep his own race alive for as long as
possible
think about it like this the night king
and the White Walkers did not start
attacking in force until they were no
longer getting crashed her Sun's up
until then they were basically just
killing trespassers all of this led me
to thinking about the prince who was
promised prophecy could that actually be
a play on words what if this is meant to
be some kind of an offering to the night
King was that prince actually promised
to the night king maybe this is why the
night king has become so active as of
lately he might be coming south to get
what he thinks is rightfully his
you see Christ her sons were good enough
for the night King to create new White
Walkers but the night King might need a
specific baby from a specific bloodline
in order to replace himself after all
one major part of this story has always
been who was the rightful heir to the
Iron Throne
maybe the Nike needs an heir of his own
who will take over for him one day many
fans already believe that the night King
cannot be defeated well the night King
may be coming to find his replacement as
we have seen in some of the previous
seasons the night King has had several
opportunities to kill Jon Snow and even
Daenerys Targaryen as of last season but
for some reason he decided to wait why
would the night King continued to allow
Jon Snow to live if he saw him as such a
big threat well maybe the night King
knows something that we don't we know
that the night king has access to the
weirwood net because we have seen him
take control of her brain Starks visions
back in season six this also makes sense
because the night king would have that
ability since he was created by the
children of the forest when they created
the night king as their weapon they most
likely transferred most of their powers
to him that would mean that the night
king may have the ability to see events
long before they even happen
in the books we are told that the green
seers are able to do this and I believe
that the night King is also able to do
that as well this leads to another big
question about the mystery of the night
king and that is why did he come back
now some people say it has to do with
the birth of the Dragons while others
say it had to do with the birth of jon
snow or even Daenerys Targaryen but what
if it has a little bit to do with both
it could have been a birth that did
cause the night king to come back but
what if that birth hasn't happened yet
what if the night king came back because
he knew that John and Daenerys would
produce a child together
some people say that Johnson Oh is the
prince who was promised but others say
that Daenerys is the princess who was
promised well maybe it is actually their
child now let me explain why I think
that could possibly be true like I said
earlier the very first time we hear
about the White Walkers accepting babies
as sacrifices was thousands of years ago
old nan said that the night's king and
the night's Queen were sacrificing their
own babies to the White Walkers that
actually led to them getting killed by
the stark of Winterfell in German who
was the king-beyond-the-wall now the
thing I find very interesting is the
fact that the night's king was a member
of House Stark that means that all the
babies he had what the night's queen
would have had stark blood therefore
most of the original White Walkers had
Starks blood from the night's king this
makes sense that the White Walkers would
want those babies because stark blood is
obviously extremely powerful now let's
fast forward to when Crestor is
sacrificing his sons they don't really
go into any of the details in this show
but in the books there is some evidence
that Crestor may have actually been a
Targaryen based on the timeline Crestor
could have actually been bloodraven son
if that's true that means the White
Walkers are taking his babies because
they have very special blood as well
that would also make sense because why
else would the knight King one crashed
her son specifically unless there was
something special about them the night
King and the White Walkers could have
been snatching babies from any of the
wildlings but they were only taken
Craster's at that time so with that in
mind that leads me to believe that the
night king is only able to make White
Walkers out of babies with either stark
blood or Targaryen blood those two
bloodlines have enough magic to create a
white Walker now if the night king ever
wanted to replace himself then he
would obviously need something a little
bit more special like a baby that has
both Stark and Targaryen blood I know
some of you may be thinking why don't
the night King just use John Snow since
he has Stark and Targaryen blood well
maybe that's because John is no longer a
baby based on what we have seen and the
stories we have heard from the past it
seems as if the night King needs a
newborn baby in order to do this the
sacrifices have always been babies as
far as we know now let's think about how
the White Walkers were actually stopped
during the first long night how did the
children of the forest and the last hero
get them to agree to go back north when
they were already winning the battle
maybe the prince who has promised
originally started as an offering to the
night king they may have promised that
whenever the baby was born the night
king would be able to get him all of
this could have been foreseen inside of
the weirwood net maybe this is why the
night king has taken such an interest in
Jon Snow he could have already killed
Jon if he really wanted to and he could
have even killed drogon when Daenerys
was on his back but he chose not to was
the night king just waiting long enough
for Jon and Daenerys to produce a child
of Ice and Fire when you think about it
the night king basically attacked the
wall at the same exact time Jon and
Daenerys were having sex the night King
may have known that was the time that
John was gonna give Daenerys his seed
and now it's time for the night King to
come south and get the Prince who was
promised to him the prince who would
eventually take the night King's place
as the leader of the White Walkers now I
know that might sound batshit crazy but
it's something else that we can think
about as we wait for the final season to
come back on the air let me know what
you think leave your questions or
opinions down below in the comments
section of the video I want to thank
everyone for stopping by and watching
today's video I really appreciate that
and I also want to thank all of you on
patreon for supporting the channel have
a great day
I'll see you soon bye
you
[Music]
you
you